احنا تكلمنا في الجزء الاول مع في
البرنامج من الحلقاتنا اليوم مع النجمه
غاده عبد الرازق عن مسلسلها تلت التلاته
والاصدقاء الكبيره اللي عملها المسلسل لكن
مع الاصداء والارشادات كمان ذكرنا انه في
جدل وعناوين كثير شفناها عن سرقه المسلسل
من مسلسلات اجنبيه ودعاوى قضائيه من كاتبه
بتقول انها صاحبه المسلسل الحقيقيه وغيرها
خلينا نلخص لكم الكلام السائد للان اولا
من وقت ما نزل بوستر العمل والاتهامات
نزلت عليه انه بيتشابه مع بوستر مسلسل
مكسيكي طيب في كمان اصوات طلعت قالت لا
ترى المسلسل ماخوذ ومقتبس من كم عمل
تانيين هم مسلسل اجنبي اسمه في فيلم اسمه
لافنج طيب وفي كمان انتقادات وكلام توجه
للكاتبه انها حولت المسلسل الى 15 حلقه في
اللحظه الاخيره لان مالح تكتب 30 حلقه
كامله وفوق كل هذا طلعت كمان كاتبه اسمها
سو شاهين اتهمت بالسرقه وقالت انها عرضت
النص على النجمه غاده عبد الرازق من قبل
وكان اسمه لعبه التغيير وانها كانت متفقه
معاها على البدء بالتصوير في نوفمبر ولكن
غاده قطعت التواصل معها والكاتبه انصدمت
بس شافت بوستر المسلسل وهي الان رفعت دعوه
قضائيه ضد غاده وكل صناع العمل واتهمتهم
بالسرقه او بسرقه العمل منها تحديدا
وطالبت في دعواها بوقف عرض المسلسل فورا
كل ما سبق هذا للان ما طلع عليه ولا اي رد
رسمي واحنا قلنا ما في الا كاتبه المسلسل
بنفسها اللي تطلع وتوضح وحتكون معنا الان
في اول مقابله لها ورد رسمي على كل الجدل
الكاتبه طبعا هبه الحسيني الكلام هذا عن
التشابه والاقتباس او ايا كان اسمه في
جمهور اتفق معه
ومعنا من القاهره مؤلفه مسلسل تلت الثلاثه
هبه الحسيني اهلا فيكي معانا يا هبه وكل
سنه وانت طيبه
وانت طيبه ميرسي قوي اهلا بك طبعا هبه
يعني المسلسل بدا عرضه وطبعا زي ما ذكرنا
الاستاذ غاده عبد الرازق انه طبعا في نجاح
في حديث عنه عامل ترند كل هذا الكلام بس
برضو مصاحبه الكثير من الجدل والجدل هذا
في الموضوع خصوصا يخصك انت بالدرجه الاولى
اللي هو القصه في كذا اتهام اول شيء في
اتهامات انه مقتبس من اعمال اجنبيه هل
شفتي هذه الاعمال
قدرت تراجعي او شيء تشوفي وجه الشبه اللي
بيتكلموا عنه الناس
بصي هو من اول ما بدانا اصلا اعلنا اصلا
عن العمل في كم كبير جدا من حمله كده تم
شنها فجاه انا مش فاهمه يعني ازاي حد
ينتقد او او يتوقع قصه حاجه من مجرد
البوستر وهو لسه ما شافهاش فمن البدايه
خالص كان فيه ربط كده غريب جدا والحقيقه
ان انا عايزه بس ابتدي كلامي كده بحاجه
اعتقد ان هي هتبقى بديهيه انه في حاجتين
لا يتفقان ابدا التكرار والتشويق ما فيهاش
حاجه مكرره تحقق تشويق والحاله اللي احنا
عايشينها دلوقتي مع المشاهدين على
السوشيال ميديا وحضراتكم اكيد بتابعوا
بدليل ان انتم معانا اصلا النهارده لو
احنا مش ناجحين انتم مش هتبقوا معنا ان
الناس قاعده على اعصابها لا عارفه مين عاش
مين مات مين جاي مين رايح اللي هيحصل
فازاي حاجه مكرره او بلغه السوء منحوته
بين قوسين هتبقى محققه تشويق يعني هوكم
ما يجتمعوش دي نقطه النقطه التانيه انا
ليه مش عارفه يعني ليه لما الخواجه بيروح
لقضيه حقيقيه او حاله نفسيه او حادثه حصلت
في بلد ما ويعملها في مسلسل في فيلم
بنسقفله وبنقول له برافو بس احنا لما نيجي
ناخد منها لاين او ناخد منها خط حادثه
حقيقيه هيلاقي الناس بتقول لك اصل انت
سارق من الخواجه لا هو الخواجه لا يمتلك
الحدث الحقيقي وانا عايزه اقول كل
البوستات اللي شفتها
والمقارنات اللي انا قريتها ما بين
المسلسل وما بين المسلسلات اخرى او افلام
اخرى كلها يعني كل الاعمال اللي تم
وقناتها كلها مستوحى من اعمال حقيقيه اذا
لو فرضنا الجدلا ان انا اخدت لاين من
الحادثه الحقيقيه دي هل انا مطلوب منك يا
كاتبه انه اشير للكاتب الامريكي او
الدنماركي او الروسي او الكوري اللي اخذ
من نفس الحادثه الحقيقيه ليه هو مش مصدري
انا مصدري الواقع الح قيقيه القضيه او
الحاله هل هل انت مستوحيه اي شيء يا هبه
من قصص حقيقيه
طبعا بس انا مش مطلوب مني ان انا احرق
مسلسلي وهو لسه بيتعرض يعني هل اطلع ارد
اطلع ارد عشان اكسب جدل يعني جدل على
السوشيال ميديا
وجدل افتراضي عشان احرق مسلسلي انا كل
اقدر اقوله من خلالكم انه
الاحداث ابعد بكتير بكتير بكثير بكثير من
اللي بيتم طرحه طيب بس بيتم
انه مو بس انه يعني مقتبس من اشياء اجنبيه
او يعني زي ما قلتي منحوت او كذا في كاتبه
طلعت واتهاماتكم ورفعت دعوه وقالت انه هي
عرضت الفكره والسيناريو
هذا على غاده تمام صح ما هي بقى نشرت مش
هي نشرت المعالجه اللي كانت نشرت المعالجه
فعلا
بيتعرض الحكم للجمهور والحكم الثاني
للقضاء لانه هي يعني برضه المعالجه اللي
نشرتها فيها برضه ثلاث اخوات وانهم
بيكونوا توائم وجريمه بترتكب وهكذا
ايه المشكله انا عندي بنتين توام واول ما
بدات اشتغل على المشاكل اللي بيعيشها
التوائم الامراض النفسيه والحالات اللي
ممكن تصاب التوائم في نفس الوقت ده انا
اتكلمت انا واستاذه غاده عن ايه الافكار
اللي ممكن نشتغل عليها
لان احنا اصلا كنت هشتغل انا واستاذه غاده
قبل كده يعني في رمضان اللي فات مش في
رمضان ده وكان عندنا مجموعه افكار كثيره
بنطرحها وبنتناقش فيها وطورنا الفكره مع
بعض اشتغلنا عليها مع بعض هي كان عندها
رغبه ان هي تشتغل على خطوط معينه لها
التحدي ليها كممثله وانا كان عندي مخزون
من القصص عن التوائب من خلال تجربتي في ان
انا انجبت توام بنتين برضه متطابقين
بالمناسبه الله يخلي لكم
الله يخليكي
فبالتالي احنا دماغنا التقت مع بعض
وخلقنا حاجه هبه حاسه انك مزعوجه جدا من
الموضوع
لا انا بس حاسه انه الموضوع دوت يعني حاسه
ان في ناس مش قادره تصدق او تستوعب او
تقتنع ان احنا في في مجتمع العربي يعني
نقدر نعمل حاجه حلوه لازم لو شفنا حاجه
حلوه نفكر على طول اول حاجه تيجي في بالنا
هو احنا واخدينها من مين لا احنا واخدين
من نفس اللي بياخد منه مين ده برده يعني
هي الفكره ان المجتمع والعالم مليء بالقصص
وفي الحواديت
الفكره انت هتتعالجها ازاي وبعدين احنا
عندنا لسه احنا دلوقتي بنرد الحلقه
الخامسه يعني
ان شاء الله يعني على خير بقيه المسلسل
يتعرض والحكم في النهايه للجمهور يعني
مفيش مفيش اي حاجه من اللي بتتقال على
السوشيال ميديا
تقدر ان هي تحكم على العشر حلقات
احنا
وعلى العموم يعني هي كمان الكاتبه الاخرى
رفعت دعوه والمحكمه راح تنظر فيه الموضوع
نحن بنشكرك على هذه التوضيحات وهذه
المداخله شكرا لك وطبعا تمنياتنا لك
بالتوفيق في المسلسل كانت معنا من القاهره
مؤلفه مسلسل ثلث الثلاثه هبه الحسيني شكرا
لك
[موسيقى]